first of all when we look at the graph
of sine you probably already learn how
to graph this in a previous lesson but
the key thing that we want to pay
attention to here is that you know
although the sine is a function C it
passes the vertical line test the
inverse of this graph is not a function
you can see that it's failing the
horizontal line test meaning that when
you draw a horizontal line you know it's
crossing the graph at more than one
point so what mathematicians decided to
do to you know get around the fact that
it's not a function is just to restrict
the domain so when you restrict the
domain what we're doing is we're just
gonna look at it from here to here so
we're just gonna look at this part of
the graph okay I'll just make a little
bit darker so you can see it because now
you can see it passes the vertical line
test this is a function it passes the
horizontal line test okay meaning it
doesn't cross it more than once so the
inverse of this graph is a function so
now how do we actually graph the inverse
well what you can do when you graph the
inverse function is you switch the X and
the y coordinates you're switching the
input in the output so let's look at
three key points here let's look at this
point here negative PI over 2 comma
negative one and what we're gonna do
here is we're just gonna write this out
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
switch the X and the y coordinates so if
we do that this is going to be negative
one negative PI over two
now remember pi is 3.14 approximately
divided by two is about one point five
seven so this point is really going to
be negative one negative one point five
seven okay so if we graph this negative
PI over two this is like negative one
point five seven so we're negative a1 is
going to be right about there okay about
two-thirds of the way and then we're
gonna go down negative one point five
seven it's gonna be right about there
okay so you're with me so far now the
point here where it goes to the origin
that of course is zero zero and when you
interchange the X in the Y coordinates
there it's just the same exact point
okay so we're gonna be right there and
then this other point PI over 2 comma 1
let's mark that one down PI over 2 comma
1 if we switch the X and the y we get 1
comma PI over 2 and again PI over 2
remember is about one point five seven
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna graph that point so one is going
to be right about here okay this is one
point five seven so this is about
thirds of the way okay and then we're
going to go up 1.5 seven which is right
about there okay now when we graph this
the graphs going to look like let's see
like this now one thing you'll notice
when you graph the inverse function it's
going to be a reflection over the line y
equals x so it's a line that has a slope
of 1 it's like a 45-degree line and it's
going to be a reflection okay
over that over that line so that's all
you have to do if you forget how to
graph the arc sine or the sine inverse
of function go ahead and graph the
original graph restrict the domain from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
and then switch the X and the y
coordinates on these three key points
and that'll be a quick way to get the
graph so I hope you enjoyed this video
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos
I'll talk to you soon